in this video we're going to do an
example problem where we calculate
internal energy and also calculate
pressure volume work
so
we know the external pressure is 1.01
times 10 to the fifth pascal
and our system
is some
balloon let's say it's a balloon of
argon gas
and initially our gas has a volume of
2.3
liters
and then it transfers the gas transfers
485 joules of energy as heat to the
surroundings
once it does that the final volume of
our system is
2.05 liters
and we're assuming here that this the
moles of gas didn't change
the question we're going to answer is
for this process
what is delta u
so what's a change in internal energy
for our system
we can use the first law of
thermodynamics to answer this
the first law tells us that the change
in internal energy delta u
is equal to
the work done
plus the heat transfer before we plug
any numbers in here the first thing i
want to do is make sure i have a good
idea of what signs everything should be
i think that's one of the trickiest
things in these kind of problems
so here
since our system transferred energy to
the surroundings and not the other way
around
q should be negative because when it
your system transfers energy to the
surroundings then its internal energy
should go down
work on the other hand
since
v2 is less than v1
the volume of our system went down which
means the surroundings had to do work on
the gas to get the volume to decrease we
would expect if the surroundings did
work on our system that would increase
the internal energy so that means the
work done here is positive
we can also calculate work because we
know the external pressure we know it's
constant
and work
can be calculated
as the external pressure times the
change in volume
and we know both of those things we know
the external pressure and we know the
initial and final volumes
so if we start plugging that in
we get that delta u is equal to
negative
485 joules
so that's our heat
we know it should have a negative sign
because the heat was transferred to the
surroundings
so negative 485 joules
minus
we should have a negative sign there
minus the external pressure 1.01
times 10 to the fifth pascals
so that's our external pressure times
our change in volume so that's our final
pressure 2.05 liters
minus our initial pressure which is 2.30
liters
we could at this point be like okay we
figured it all out we just have to stick
all of these numbers in the calculator
and we're done
and that's probably what my first
instinct would often be
but there there's one more thing that we
should check before we actually plug in
the numbers and and have a party
and that's our units we have our heat in
terms of joules
we probably want our change in internal
energy in terms of joules too
on this other side we're calculating our
work here and we have pascals
so pascals times
so we have joules and joules we have
pascals times liters
so then the question is okay we're doing
joules minus
pascals times liters
we need to make sure that whatever we
calculate here in terms of work also has
units of joules otherwise we will be
we'll be subtracting two things that
don't have the same units and that's bad
we'll have to do some sort of unit
conversion first so let's just double
check that pascals times liters
will give us joules
so the way i did this is by converting
everything to the same units
so if you take joules which is already
si units we can actually simplify it
more
in terms of
other sa units so a joule is equal to 1
kilogram
meters squared
per second squared
so joules is equal to 1 joule is equal
to 1 kilogram meter squared over a
second squared
one pascal
pascals are also in terms of are also si
units and if we convert pascals to
kilograms meters and seconds we get that
one pascal is one
kilogram
per meter second squared
what this tells us is that we have to
multiply this by units of volume
and whatever we multiply it by should
give us units of joules so what we need
to do here is convert our liters
to meters cubed
and if we do that everything is in terms
of kilograms meters and seconds
this meters cancels out with one of
these and we end up with one kilogram
meter squared per second squared on both
sides so then everything is in terms of
joules
that's not the only way you could have
made sure that the units made sense
um you could have converted them to
something else but basically you just
have to make sure that all of the units
you're using in your equation
match each other if you're going to add
them or subtract them all of this is to
say that we need to make sure we convert
liters to meters cubed so that
everything works out in terms of joules
so if we do that we get that minus 485
joules
1.01 times 10 to the fifth pascals
times negative 0.25 liters which is the
change in volume which is negative the
volume went down so the change in volume
should be negative and then we have to
add one more thing here
to convert our liters
to meters cubed
so 1 liter is equal to 1
10 to the minus third
meters cubed
so now our liters cancel out and pascals
times meters cubed gives us joules
so that gives us
that delta u our change in internal
energy is negative 485 joules and then
if we plug this all into our calculator
to calculate the work
we get positive
25.25 joules
so if we add our heat and our work here
we get that the overall change in
internal energy for this process is
negative 406
joules
so the key things to remember here for
this kind of problem is to double check
your signs for work and heat and also to
make sure all of your units match